et tout d'abord une petite mise en
contexte évidemment on va parler du
réseau ferroviaire canadien un des plus
vastes un des plus importants dans le
monde 48 mille kilomètres au total de
voies ferrées qui parcourt qui
sillonnent le pays
c'est énorme et on va voir aussi dans la
prochaine carte que donc on va
s'apercevoir l'instant même qu' il ya
surtout deux grands géants qui ont
historiquement prédominé ce paysage on
le voit les petites lignes rose et bleu
canadien pacifique et canadien national
au fil des ans ces deux grandes
compagnies décide de se défaire de
petits réseaux plus marginaux moins
rentables on va changer de quartier on
va voir où se situent ces réseaux là qui
sont surtout dans l'est du pays décidée
réseau acc axa or et c'est là qu'entre
en scène des petites compagnies comme
mm20 qui vont tenter de rentabiliser
donc ces réseaux ferroviaires avec
notamment au départ du transport de bois
mais là le pétrole et le gaz de schiste
entre en ligne de compte il ya trois ans
environ et ont passé une prochaine carte
que je veux que je vais généré ici pour
vous dans le nord des etats-unis voyez
c'est le dakota du nord c'est là d'où
provient le pétrole qui est transporté
vers lac-mégantic dans le cas qui nous
occupe toutes les nappes toutes les
tâches jaunes sont les endroits il ya
des fortes réserves de gaz et de pétrole
de schiste donc d'une halle dakota du
nord
c'est de cet endroit là que part très
parce que le réseau pipeline n'est pas
assez important encore est acheminer le
pétrole par des villes fortement
peuplées on passe à minneapolis on passe
à chicago et detroit et ensuite toronto
et de là vers montréal dans ces grandes
villes évidemment les mesures de
sécurité sont beaucoup plus strictes que
dans des petites municipalités comme lac
mégantic et on va vendre pour suivre
cette route de ce train de ce pétrole
vert de lac mégantic
montréal vous ne voyez ici c'est à cet
endroit qu'on a semblé 73 wagons qui
vont se diriger dans la nuit de vendredi
à samedi de la semaine dernière vers
lac-mégantic de là comment cette ligne
rose qui désigne mm an et son travail et
son réseau ça commence à saint-jean
iberville farnham on se rappelle qu à
farnham la ville le conseil municipal a
voté en faveur de la suspension des
activités de même en poursuivant notre
autre commande iv le magog sherbrooke à
sherbrooke le maire sévigny s'est plaint
de la présence de
mais maître de ses activités dans son
dans sa ville c'est là qu'on effectue un
changement de coeur et de landes
traverse le maine la chambre de
représentants pas plus tard qu'ils aient
voté en faveur d'une révision des règles
qui entourent le transport de matières
dangereuses et ensuite on se transporte
vers le nouveau-brunswick où il ya déjà
eu des accidents à saint-léonard
notamment et là aussi on s'inquiète de
ce transport de matières dangereuses
tout ça s'est effectué avec d un
équipement de plus en plus vieillissant
pour rentabiliser pensent certains donc
ce type de transport de marchandises on
voit ici ce fameux wagons-citernes c'est
le dot 111 d ôter 111 wagons-citernes
que l'on retrouve sur les chemins de fer
dans 70% des cas en amérique du nord
malgré les rapports inquiétants et
publié aux états unis depuis les années
90 et au canada en 2005 par la bureau de
bureau de la sécurité du transport
on va voir maintenant de plus près ce
wagon citerne là on dit que son
revêtement est beaucoup trop mèze pas
assez protecteur trop vulnérable 2-1 aux
perforations et aussi à la montée de
pression qui survient car il ya un
incendie comme dans le cas de
lac-mégantic précisément donc ces
avertissements
ces points-là ces éléments l'enquêté
souligne anne de nombreuses reprises et
c'est en toute légalité que malgré tout
circule aux états unis et au canada
évidemment la l'industrie rechignent à
l'idée de changer tout ça ces wagons là
ça coûterait cher et maintenant on va
terminer avec un portrait global des
sanctions financières pour toutes les
entreprises et les individus qui donc
enfreignent la loi sur la sécurité
ferroviaire au canada sédunois
juridiction fédérale évidemment jusqu'à
50000 $ pour les individus et jusqu'à 1
million $ pour les personnes morales
donc les entreprises donc
potentiellement mm à alors voilà donc un
portrait de la situation la route du
pétrole